بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما بعد يقول الله تعالى قل من رب
السماوات والارض قل
الله قل افات اخذتم من دونه اولياء لا
يملكون لانفس م نفعا ولا
ضرا قل هل يستوي الاعمى والبصير ام هل
تستوي الظلمات
والنور ام جعلوا لله شركاء خلقوا كخلقه
فتشابه الخلق
عليهم قل الله خالق كل شيء وهو الواحد
القهار قوله
تعالى قل من رب السماوات والارض
قل ايها
الرسول ايها
النبي ونبينا صلى الله عليه
وسلم لم يخاطبه الله سبحانه في كتابه
باسمه فلم
يقل يا محمد قط
في القران
وقال
ذلك للانبياء
وذلك من اكرام الله
سبحانه
له فالتقدير يكون
قل ايها
الرسول
النبي
والنبي
اولى
بالايات التي
توجه
للمؤمنين في الايات التي انزلت في
المدينه السور
المدنيه
ف النبي اولى
بالتقدير
واما في السور
المكيه السور الموجهه الى المخالفين في
اصل الدين والسور المكيه
فالتقدير ايها
الرسول يقول تعالى قل من رب السماوات
والارض سلهم من رب السماوات والارض اي من
مربي السماوات والارض ومن في السماوات
والارض س يجيبون بانه
الله فان لم
يجيبوا
تكبرا قل
الله فاجب لهم لقنه سبحانه وتعالى السؤال
والجواب قل الله اي لا جواب
غير
الله
والله
اسم
علم لله تعالى وهو
ابرز
اسمائه وهو ماخوذ من الاله
الاله اي
المعبود
بحق حبا
وتعظيما ايش الفرق بين العبوديه
والالوهيه الفرق ان
العباده
معروفه
و الهيه او
الالوهيه فهي العباده مع الحب والتعظيم
ف قوله تعالى قل
الله يعني الله سبحانه وتعالى وهو المستحق
للعباده حبا
وتعظيما قل
سلهم قل يا ايها الرسول افات اخذتم من
دونه اولياء لا يملكون لانفسهم نفعا ولا
ضره هذه مهمه في قراءه
القران لما تجد
الهمزه سابقه
للواو او سابقه
اتخذتم او كلما
جاءكم
افكلما كثير في
القران ما معنى هذه
الكلمه الجواب ان الهمزه للاستفهام
يعني هل
اتخذتم
اتخذتم والفاء حرف
عطف لكن حرف العطف
لا تشتبه مع غيرها في مثل هذا التركيب
وانما الذي يشتبه الهمس فاذا جاءت
فاتخذت صار في لبس في في المعنى
والتركيب
واشتباه فلذلك
يقول
العلماء حرف
الاستفهام
له الصداره يعني تقول اتخذتم يعني بناء
على ما سبق انتم تقولون الله رب السماوات
والارض وهو
مربيها وهو مالكها وهو
مدبرها فبناء على ذك اتخذت من دونه اولياء
يعني تعبدون غيره لماذا ما السبب الحامل
لكم الدافع لكم على ان تعبدوا
غيره هل السبب انكم اتخذتم من دونه اولياء
يعني الهه لا يملكون لانفسهم نفعا ولا
ضار هل هذا الذي
حصل
يعني انتم تعلمون ان الله هو رب السماوات
والارض وحده دون ما سواه ثم تتخذون من دون
الهه لا يملكون لانفسهم نفعا ولا
ضرا
اي شيء
ارداكم الى هذه الهوه
واي واي
شيطان دفعكم وحملكم على ذلك قال تعالى قل
هل يستوي الاعمى والبصير وا هل تستوي
الظلمات
والنور هل يستوي الاعمى والبصير روى
الطبراني عن مجاهد انه قال الاعمى
هنا الكافر
والبصير
المؤمن وقال
الظلمات
الضلاله
والنور
الهدى وقول اخر
الاعمى هذه الاصنام اصنامهم
والهت والبصير هو الله سبحانه وتعالى ام
هل تستوي الظلمات
والنور
الظلمات الشرك والنور هدايه
الله وعلى كلا المعنيين قل هل يستوي
الاعمى والبصير كيف تسوون بين
هذين الاعمى مضاد للبصير والظلمات
والنور
لا يستويان يقول ام جعلوا لله
شركاء
جعلوا يعني زعموا نسبوا لله شركاء شاركوه
في
الخلق خلقوا كخلقه اي
هذه الاله هؤلاء الشركاء خلقوا كخلق
الله هذا
سؤال هذا السؤال
هو البرهان العقلي وهذا
سؤال انكاري يسمى استفهام انكاري ايش
الاستفهام
الانكاري الاستفهام
الانكاري الذي معناه
النفي
يعني ناخذ الاستفهام ونحط محله النفي
نقول جعلوا لله شركاء لم يخلقوا كخلقه
فتشابه الخلق
عليهم او
هو لغير ذلك على كل حال هو ينكر عليهم
سبحانه ويقول جعلوا لله شركاء خلقوا كخلقه
فتشابه الخلق
عليهم
يعني هل هناك الهه مع الله يعبدونها هذه
الالهه خلقت ولها جزء من
الخلق فلذلك اختلط عليهم الخلق واختلط
اختلطت عليهم الالهه ومن يستحق العباده
فلذلك عبدوا غير الله هل هذا هو السبب
طبعا الجواب لا باجماع
كل
العقلاء يقول تعالى قل الله خالق كل شيء
وهو الواحد
القهار فبما انه خالق كل
شيء
ف بعد ان ذكر هذه الصفه انه خالق كل
شيء ذكر انه
الواحد
القهار الواحد سبحانه
وتعالى الذي
هو واحد في ربوبيته وفي خلقه وفي اسمائه
وفي صفاته وهو الواحد في
عبوديته فلا يستحق احد
العبوديه والاخلاص والتبتل الا الله
سبحانه
وتعالى يقول تعالى خالق كل
شيء
كل شيء مخلوق اليس كذلك يعني هل الله
سبحانه وتعالى
شيء الشيء في لغه
العرب
هو ال
الموجود تقول هذا شيء يعني هذا شيء
موجود
فالشيء الله سبحانه
وتعالى لم يخلق نفس ولم يخلق
اسماء نفسه ولا صفاته
سبحانه
فبعض وكذلك قوله
تعالى على كل شيء قدير
برضه ياتي بعض المفسرين ويقول على ما يشاء
قدير هذا غير دقيق فالله سبحانه وتعالى
قدير على ما يشاء وعلى ما لا لا يشاء
سبحانه ما ما الذي حملهم على ذلك قالوا
الله سبحانه وتعالى شيء واسماءه وصفاته
شيء
واشياء
ف ما
حبينا يتبادر للذهن ان الله خالق نفسه او
خالق اسمائه
وصفاته
او الى غير ذلك وهذا قول ضعيف وبعيد
جدا لان قوله تعالى خالق كل شيء يعني كل
شيء من من شانه انه مخلوق واما غير
المخلوقات ال الله سبحانه وتعالى غير
مخلوق اسماؤه صفاته غير مخلوقه فهذا لا
يتبادر للذهن ابدا ولا حاجه لهذه الحاشيه
كل
شيء خالق كل شيء وهو سبحانه مقدر لكل شيء
هذه عقيده
المسلمين قديما
وحديثا ان الله
تعالى لا يخلق شيئا الا
الله ما من شيء مخلوق الا والله
خالقه فالخير مخلوق والشر مخلوق والله
سبحانه وتعالى خالق كل شيء
لكن لا يخلق
الشر من اجل
الشر بل الله سبحانه وتعالى قد
ياذن ويقدر شيئا من الشر الذي هو شر من
وجه لكن الحكمه
تقتضي وجود هذا الشيء فهو خالق كل شيء وهو
الواحد
القهار وتمام
القهر هو صاحب الذي له تمام القهر هو الذي
له تمام التوحيد سبحانه
وتعالى والقهر في الاصل
الغلبه فالله سبحانه وتعالى هو
القهار هو الذي متغلب على
جميع ما في السماوات وما في
الارض فهو واحد في ربوبيته وواحد في
اسمائه
وصفاته واحد
في
الوهيته يعني بانه معبود وحده دون ما سواه
وهو الوحيد الذي معبود
بحق وهذا اصل معنى لا اله الا الله لا اله
الا الله اي لا معبود بحق الا
الله بعض الناس يخطئ في هذا ونحن ننبه على
هذا كثيرا لماذا لان الناس اذا قراوا
القران فانهم سيحملون معاني
القران على احوالهم وعلى واقعهم
وهذا انما يحسن بالقارئ القران بعد ان
يتقن
فهم الزمن الذي انزل فيه القران والمكان
والناس في الاصل حتى بعد ذلك يقيس نفسه
عليهم وهذا هو العلم وهذا هو شان العلماء
كما ذكرنا مرارا
وتكرارا
ففي
زمننا كثير
من الشان في هذا
الزمن انتشر بين
الناس ليس فقط عباده غير الله سبحانه
وتعالى ولكن ايضا انتشر
الالحاد يعني عدم الايمان بوجود خ
وهذا اشبه
بالجنون ولم يقل به عاقل في
التاريخ الا نادرا نادرا بعض السفهاء
يقولون
هذا الذين ارسل اليهم النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يؤمنون بوجود الله ويؤمنون
ب ان الله هو
الخالق
الرازق ال
سبحانه وتعالى
المالك لكن يعبدون غيره معه زعما منهم ان
هذه المعبودات المالو
هت هي تقربهم من الله يقول تعالى ما
نعبدهم الا ليقربونا الى الله
زلفا وقال تعالى هؤلاء شركاؤنا عند الله
هذا قول في سوره يونس قول المشركين
فهم يعبدون غير الله ظنا منهم ان هذه
الالهه تشفع لهم عند
الله بقضاء
الحوائج ف الله سبحانه وتعالى يذكر هنا
كيف تعبدون غير الله بالعباده التي لا
يستحقها الا الله ثم تظنون انكم تتقربون
بذلك الى الله كيف ما الذي اوصلكم الى
هذا كيف
تعبدون غير الله بالعباده التي تعبدون بها
الله او بقسط زائدا من
العباده على ما تعبدون بها الله ثم تظنون
ان هذه الالهه تشفع لكم عند الله كيف هي
اذا كانت اذا كانوا هذول
الصالحين هؤلاء الصالحون الذين تزعمون
انهم صالحون
وتعبدون
الاولياء كيف يرضون بان يصرف شيء
من العبادات اليهم كيف اذا كانوا فعلا
صالحين كيف يرضون
بذلك وهذه مسائل لا تزال منتشره في
الارض لا تزال منتشره في الارض وكان شيء
من هذا نزع من هذه ونبتت
نابته بين المسلمين في عباده القبور وما
يزعمون بانهم اولياء وهذه العقائد تسربت
الى
المسلمين عن
طريق الاقليه المسلمه التي
تستوطن بين
اي اكثريه
مشركه فيتابرون ما عندهم علماء يتاثرون
بهذه العقائد
الفاسده يعبدون اصحاب
القبور ويقولون هذه ليست عبادات وانما
هي وانما هذا هو ولي وصاحب القبر يسمع
وانا ادعوه ما ادعوه انا اساله هو يسمعني
اصلا وحتى وصل
الامر الى
ان كثيرا منهم صار
يعتقد صار
يعتقد في هؤلاء بان لهم
تصرف في خلق الله في ملك
الله و سياتي ذكر
هذا فيما بعد ان شاء الله ونكتفي بهذا
القدر والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا
محمد سه
الر number
16 الله سبحانه
وتعالى
‏again as we mention before this is
important and that is
that important for us
understand قران and ar قران
are
cri who
ar are geared
‏a l of because the time place in when
person pi up قران as a matter of
naturally when a person picks up any
book the first thing the person does and
it is
almost it is almost something that you
cann help the most natural thing in the
world pick up any
b and to imagine
‏the events the arguments the statements
the
definition that the auth is speaking to
you the
reader and the references the author is
making and etc is all geared towards you
the
reader geared towards your time and
place you live in the most natural thing
in the
world however
‏this cuse us
gross the ar this is
why صلى الله عليه
وسلم
life companions enemies everything was
incredi
and
قران
time when you know in our time in our
place super this kind of post modern
movement
and kind of disposable environment that
we live in
we of
people
‏belal and that articulates that our
time and our environment
has unnatural en that
har
to
because ar
‏place
open logical arguments we expect that
these are logical arguments geared
towards affirming the existence of a
creator and they are to extent but
that's
not what most of the arguments arum
quar الله سبحانه
وتعالى قران
menic arguments that are geared
towards refuting those who disb in a
creator
قران
but
humanity
علس people in exence of allah they
believe allah
the however they worship other allah
along with him either because they
believe that these things that they
worship
will act as anced on their behalf
because they believe these things
worship people
‏as
of
more toward pantheism this is what the
majority of mankind struggles with the
worship people or things that they
believe are holy people holy things holy
places
‏their
beh so most of the quran logical
arguments are geared towards refuting
this and this argument here and the
majority of this chapter is dedicated to
that precisely الله سبحانه وتعالى
translates understand based
on based on
this
concept he says
‏say them who is the creat sustainer
owner of the heaven
and say them
الله say
them based on
that you you believe allah the creat yet
in of that you believe the cre the
sustainer
‏in spite that you worship other
than indiv or things that
cann benefit their own in the har in
le mean independently from
allah
them
‏based on
that how can you equival the two how can
you make the worship of allah the
worship that which owns nothing the one
who owns nothing has created nothing
sustain nothing how can you make them
the
same
the is blind
and
can
‏equ or is darkness and light
equal the answer of course is no this is
a rical argument he
says or is it that they associated with
الله
those whom claim have
created with
الله and is bel
قصل الله عليه
وسلم if you can affirm that other
created
tr
and this others
creation that he is
responsible
became mied ‏with allah the point could
not the perhaps that is happen that
caused to worship
other them theat
of
he all س سبحانه
وتالى والمصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحبه
ا